LAND.
ELL C T    NN ARMED RUSSI  G T
HOUSE WITHS.ARDESPERAT, AND SO
NCHES.
UKRAINIANCES
TH CKES ADR OWN.THEY MUS T FOODI
HER THAN
IMPOSINGALIKELY HAVING
STREETS QUT,
TORM WHERE
NOBODY IS IN WILL STILL HAFIGHT
HAVE BLOWN MIDDLE O IN
THE LA
RUSSIA CLOSE
>> THE PEO UNO
AND THEY'VREY GONE LTERSE RUSSI
UNDEROUND AS MUCH AS THEY HINGSG
BOMBED.
A LOT OFPL THE BK OF
THEIR HEADILMED, PBEUSHE AHEAD R
RUSSIAN CONTROL.
>> Reporter: HTEPS,000 PEOPLE A
OUT HEREUT THERE'S NO
TO KNOW.
THSIA IMPOSEON
ERE ISPENDINNIGHTS SCURRYING
BETWEEN SHELTER.
OT WORDS  PUTINN'T COOLED U
ADVANC OF NUHILATION CARRIESLIED
N SIA WA
R HEAVY
EVEN THE RUSSIAN OHO
SPUR OF THS ALMOST
>> THEY IA TION AMOSCOW ABOUPARG
MBBAS                       BOMT
IT WILSAYST YOU'LL NEED TO TRA M
PEOPLE BUT YOU'VD MOST THEIR.AT
NUCLEAR WABUT YOU MUST
UNDEND, THESEN TND IN RUSSIA NO
SUPPORTS THESE MOVES.
THIS LIBERATED ROAD IS WHERE
E TIN MADED T BOSUS OF OFFICIAL
. THE FCANARENS AN
WALKING AROUND DOOR
ASKING PEOPLE FOR THEIR VOS
ANCLERE'S OF R
AREAS BECOMING PART  TE MAY ENA
GE THE THED PERHAPS.
SHOULD P STARTLING
RUSSIAN'S STRUCIT
BE OALITY UNFOLDHAT'S THE
MAN KNOWN AS THEU CAD DURING TH
HEAVILYFFERIN MALLN.
ITO SEE THAT
WITH HI
AND BACK HERINSTATA RETURN, MOR
YS IN THMANG
O OF ETERANS RETURNING TO
L AFTER BEG
PRISIN RUSSIA.VOLUNTEERS WERE CT